hello everyone I hope you all had an
excellent weekend and here is the game
from round five of the 2018 alta box
Norway championship that will surely
improve your Sunday it's a game between
Fabiano Caruana and Sergei hurricane and
it's you know quite a game it's a game
between two challengers Sergey Kerrigan
being the 2016 World Chess Championship
challenger and Fabiano car wanna being
the 2018 World Chess Championship
challenger and I was extremely happy
that like all of you knew who the person
in the photo was in my last video it was
of course Boris Gelfand so I'm I'm
extending this game and let's check out
another photo also a person you know so
let's see it I hope I hope it rings a
bell it as it's a photo from when this
person was really young so here it is I
don't think you have to look look at him
for too long to realize who it is but I
thought it was a nice photo to show for
this game and we do have one one or two
photos from this game so here it is a
nice photo of Fabiano Caruana and
there's kurakin on the right firmly
gripping his king and an unidentified a
woman in the background if anyone knows
who this is a do share in the comments
and we also have one more photo but
we're gonna keep that one for after we
check out the game so let's see it it's
around five Caruana versus Kerrigan and
we do have the standings after this game
the standings aren't really you know to
the point as some players have played
only four games some players have played
five games since the Tingler and left
the tournament it's a you know quite
quite a blow to the 2018 Norway LT Box
changed the tournament so let's see it
c4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and c5 so
we have the English openings the English
opening to Knights variation a Knight to
f3 knight c6 III Bishop to b4 Queen c2
Bishop captures Queen captures and Queen
to e7 so black gives up the bishop pair
early on in the game but he will have
enough compensation
be three and we have castles Bishop to
b2 rook e8 and a3 now a5 a very nice
move preventing white from expanding
further on the on the Queen side and
also some rock lifting ideas in the
future may be possible
we have h3 b6 now Bishop to e2 Bishop to
b7 and gases b5 by kurakin pawn captures
night this captures on b5 attacking the
Queen Queen to c2 and E for now
attacking the knight on f3 nice to h2
and now comes Queen to g5 so already you
can see black black is extremely active
but you know not all is as it seems as
it often is in chess karana plays F 4
and F 4 is one of those moves where
you're you're not very glad white played
this and the White has a very nice pawn
chain here g4 will be definitely a
possibility and it's one of those
moments where you definitely don't want
to play each captures on f3 but you know
that you are going to play it and simply
moving the Queen is the best idea for
black here but it's when you're playing
a game it's impossible not to capture
this as you do have a light square
Bishop on b7 you do want to activate it
correcting displayy captures on f3 on
poisson so we have Knight captures on f3
attacking the Queen and Queen to g3 now
and like I said it's a it's quite a
poisonous position black is very active
here you know there are you know some
sneaky ideas here lurking lurking in the
background the bishop is now very active
on b7 when these Knights move and rook
to f2 a very nice defensive move by
Caruana and to really to really see the
power behind rook to f2 let's let's
check out what happens if white plays a
slow move such as rock c1 you know
bringing a rook into the game place
again and an open line but let's see why
why is this losing and why was a rock to
have to such an important move for
Fabiano do pause the video here and you
know I will give it a couple of seconds
as usual for
to decide what we want to do it Sunday I
know some of you might be lazy but it's
very nice idea you're gonna you know be
very happy if you if you find it so you
are you are Bobby here defeat Sergey
Karjakin in this you know a variation
that never happened so for those of you
who founded congratulations
you know once again you really know how
to how to enjoy your Sundays if you
found a route captures on e3 it's a very
nice idea but it's not the best idea
rook captures only three it's very nice
because if pawn captures then Knight
captures on e3 does come with an attack
on the Queen and also there is the
threat of checkmate the problem with
this variation and it's such a stupid
move that I really I really have to show
this to you the reason why this isn't
completely winning is because white has
bishop to a6 such a silly variation but
the queen is now protecting from
checkmate on g2 and black really I mean
what do you do here of course you're
gonna capture the Queen after Knight
captures simply Bishop captures on b7
attacking the rook that is undefended
the knight is undefended this Knight is
undefended and after black plays Knight
to e3 threatens checkmate once again and
attacks the rook on f1 simply rope to f2
again your rook is under attack and the
night after we move the rook rook b8
Bishop captures on c6 and White has
plenty of compensation for the Queen so
although rook captures on e3 in this
position is a very nice idea it's it's
not a winning idea the winning move is
actually Knight to f4 and from Knight to
a4 there really is no defense against
Queen captures and g2 whatever you play
is losing if you capture it then comes
rogue captures of course there is no way
to prevent Queen captures and g2 Rock f2
doesn't work you simply capture with the
Queen and you know there is really
nothing for 4 wife to do here it's it's
all over
so in this position look if to a very
important idea by Fabi
we have rook to the 8th Bishop to c4 and
now Knight to f6
as you see the bishop and rook are
eyeing that f7 points
ix to have six a very nice idea by
kurakin Bishop captures on f6g captures
on f6 and now doubling up rooks and EF
file we have looked to d6 defending the
f6 pawn we have before pawn captures
pawn captures and now comes rock to e7
why doesn't Knight captures on before
work
well if Knight captures then you have
this Bishop captures on f7 and if Bishop
captures on f7 this comes when an attack
on the rook King captures and now
unfortunately not the romantic King
Queen captures on h7 but rather Queen
captures on c7 attacking the bishop
attacking the rook if the rook moves the
queen is attacked it's all over for
black here once you defend this rocky 7
then comes knight Knight to g5 check
opening up an attack with double groups
towards the f6 pawn you force black to
capture the night and after Queen
captures Queen captures on d6 and a yes
black does have two pieces for the rook
but it's it doesn't do him all that much
the knight is under attack on before
after you move the knight
then comes work to a5 attacking the
Queen and the night and after Queen
moves then you simply grab two pieces
for the rook and you know you are up
upon but it's so the position is so much
better for white you don't even care
about any pawns so after I capture some
before rook to e7 immediately kurakin
guards that f7 pawn we have b5 attacking
the knight in 95 and now Knight to d4
brush up to see it with some sneaky
ideas of Bishop capturing on h3 King to
h1 not allowing it
King to g7 defending the f6 pawn and now
Bishop to e2 King to h8 a very nice idea
by kurakin once again
now if rook captures on f6 then Bishop
captures and h3 will be will be deadly
what you do here Queen captures is a
threat of checkmate Rock will have to
have to block this but then comes rook
to h6 threatening all sorts of all sorts
of discoveries and after King g1 but to
d7 now
Queen h2 the checkmate is a threat and
white will be in huge trouble here
so after into h8 we have Queen to c3
now Fabi aligns the queen with the king
and h8 and again it's not all that easy
to find a move here from black King to
g7 returning the King to defend the f6
pawn bishop to d1 we have King back to
g8 and now Bishop the c2 Queen to h4
rock to that for now attacking the Queen
Queen to g3 and Bishop to f5 now Bobby
wants to exchange the only the only well
not the only but one of the strongest
pieces Kerrigan has and that gives him
all this counter play with all of these
threats of capturing on h3 so Bishop to
b7 now there is a different threat now
Queen captures on h3 will be a terrible
threat of course Queen G to checkmate is
still a threat but even if that is
defended then Queen to h3 will also be
an idea so Bishop to e4 again Fabia
wants to exchange this strong Bishop
Bishop back to see it and now Queen to
a3 if Abby doesn't want to repeat moves
and you know perhaps draw the game by
threefold repetition but it's always
nice to repeat a couple of times if you
want to reach time control faster King
back to g7 and now Queen to a8 attacking
the strong Bishop and c8 Bishop captures
on h3 now this is one of those positions
where you don't really have a good move
but it's very hard to find I use for
move here simply simply moving the
bishop would be the best thing to do for
black and then Fabi would finally be
able to exchange this and then like
we'll be left with pretty much no
counter play so instead hurricane you
know goes down swinging
he plays Bishop captures on h3 we have G
captures on h3 Queen captures on h3 King
to g1 and now rook captures on d4 this
was Carrigan's idea and what's the idea
behind rook captures angry for if we
capture son d4 then Queen G to recheck
Bishop blocks and now Knight to g4
threatening Queen - H - checkmate after
row captures Queen captures white will
be half a piece but with all this
activity perhaps black can hold this
through
this was Corrigan's idea the problem is
after this move rook captures and before
he missed one very important idea after
Fabi played this if it's all over so
another very nice position for you to
analyze I feel free to pause the video
here and find the move that wins Fabi
the game I will get give it a couple of
seconds as usual so for those of you who
found it
congratulations you are an excellent
maneuver of Bishops and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy the show here of
how we played Bishop to g2 once you see
it it all makes sense now
the queen is attacked and instead of
capturing but the pawn now rook is also
attacking the rook there is no useful
move here for black you do have to move
the Queen your queen is under attack in
the game Queen to g3 was played but now
comes Luke captures on d4 and now there
is really no counter play here Knight to
g4 was played but now rook captures on
g4 isn't necessary Fabi simply played
rope to f3 and after Queen to e1 check
Bishop to f1 was played and now it
this is move for the one time control
has been reached you know no player is
in time trouble but it was in this
position that Sergei Carrick in the 2016
World Chess Championship Challenger
resigned the game there's really no
point in continuing this he is down a
whole rook and it would be pointless to
even consider continuing playing this
game so a very nice game by Fabiano and
a first win for him in this tournament
and a very important one as he already
lost his game against Magnus Carlsen so
this brings him back to 50% we do have a
photo of this moment after Carrick and
resigned you know fob is all like you
know yeah I just you know I just come
here I play some games I win games you
know no big deal that's that's just how
I roll and we do have the photo of the
well not the photo we don't have the
final standings after round 5 not the
final standings but the standings after
round 5 so it's not really nicely done
as some players have played five games
some players have played for like
Fabiano and Wesley so
we were in left but it will give you a
general idea about the standings so
crossing first place with three and a
half out of five completely destroying
the field to two wins 0 losses 3 draws
then he Cara Nakamura 0 and 0 losses 5
draws definitely taking it easy
it would seem but not really his games
were really really interesting Kirk in
two and a half out of five
all right now as well two and a half out
of five and Vishwanathan Anand
two and a half out of five another one
with zero losses zero wins and five
draws then comes Fabiano who is now back
to 50% to an two out of four then my
media off two out of five Wesley so two
out of four maxime Bashir two out of
five and dinkler and who unfortunately
have had to leave the tournament well no
longer important to the standings so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check - all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon would probably another
game from round five of the 2018 Alti
box Norway championship so yeah thank
you and have a great rest of the Sunday